so you're right in Homewood days about
Hitler
and uh
in part that he was not a very
impressive person I say that
the quote is let me read it okay uh he
wasn't a senior officer in four years of
war he rose no higher than the rank of
Corporal he had no formal education
perhaps you mean his resume yeah his
resume was not impressive he had no
formal education no professional skills
no political background he wasn't a
successful businessman or a union
activist he didn't have friends or
relatives in high places nor any money
to speak of uh so how did uh he amass so
much power
what ideology what circumstances enabled
the rise of the Third Reich
again I can't tell you the why
I can tell you the how I don't think it
was inevitable
I think that a few if a few things were
different there would have been no no
Third Reich that would have been no
Nazism no no Holocaust again this is the
tragedy if it would have been inevitable
then you know what can you do this is
the the laws of of history or the laws
of physics but the tragedy is no it was
Decisions by humans that led to that
direction
and you know even from the Viewpoint of
of the Germans
um we know for for a fact it was an
unnecessary path to take because you
know in the 1920s and 30s the Nazis said
that
um this unless Germany take this road it
will never be prosperous it will never
be successful all the other countries
will keep stepping on it this was their
their their uh claim and we know for a
fact this is this is false why because
they took that road
they lost the Second World War and after
they lost then they became one of the
most prosperous countries in the world
because their enemies that defeated them
evidently supported them and allowed
them to become such a prosperous and
successful Nation so you know if you can
lose the war and still be so successful
obviously you could just have script the
war you didn't need it I mean you really
had to have the war in order to have a
prosperous Germany in the United States
absolutely not and it's the same with
Japan it's the same as Italy
so um uh it was not inevitable it was
not the forces of history that
necessitated it follows Germany to take
uh this path
I think part of it is part of the appeal
of of again Hitler was a very very
skillful storyteller
sold people a story the fact that he was
nobody
made it even more effective because
people at that time they after the
defeat of the of the first world war
after the repeated economic crisis of
the 1920s in Germany people felt
betrayed by all the uh established
Elites by all the established
institutions all these professors and
politicians and industrialists and
Military all the big people they led us
to a disastrous War they led us to
humiliation so we don't want any of them
and then you have this nobody
a Corporal with no money with no
education with no titles with nothing
and it tells people I'm one of you
and this made him this was one reason
why he was so popular
and then the story he told
when you look at stories at the
competition between different stories
and between stories fiction and the
truth
the truth has two big problems
the truth tends to be complicated and
the truth tends to be painful
the real story of let's talk about
Nations the real story of every nation
is complicated
and it contains some painful episodes we
are not always good we sometimes do bad
things now if you go to people and you
tell them a complicated and painful
story many of them don't want to listen
the advantage of fiction is that it can
be made as simple
and as painless or attractive as you
want it to be because it's fiction
and then what you see is that
politicians like Hitler they create a
very simple story we are the heroes we
always do good things everybody is
against us everybody is trying to to to
trample us and
um this is very attractive one of the
things people don't understand about
Nazism and fascism we teach in schools
about Fascism and Nazism as this
ultimate Evil the ultimate monster in
human history and
some level this is this is wrong
because it make people
um it actually exposes us why because
people hear of fascism is this monster
and then when you hear the actual
fascist story what fascists tell you
is always very beautiful and attractive
fascists are people who come and tell
you you are wonderful
you belong to the most wonderful group
of people in the world you're beautiful
you are ethical everything you do is
good you have never done anything wrong
that all these evil monsters out there
that are out to get you and they are
causing all the problems in the world
and when people hear that you know it's
like looking in the mirror
and seeing something very beautiful hey
I'm beautiful I've we've never done
anything wrong we are victims everybody
is again and when you look and you heard
in school that fascism that fascists are
monsters and you look in the mirror you
see something very beautiful and you say
I can't be a fascist because fascists
are monsters and this is so beautiful so
it can't be
but when you look in the fascist mirror
you all you never see a monster you see
the most beautiful thing in the world
and that's the danger this is the
problem you know with Hollywood's you
know I look at Voldemort in Harry Potter
who would like to follow this this creep
yeah and you look at Darth Vader this is
not somebody you would like to follow
Christianity got things much better when
he described the devil as being very
beautiful and attractive that's the
danger
that you see something is very beautiful
you don't understand the monster
underneath